tout le monde n'arrête pas de parler
tout à aider haïti
ils disent que tu lui as mangé l'oignon
franchement j'ai jamais mangé le lion de
de quelqu'un ou je sais pas quoi
on n'est pas partis plus d'une minute ça
suffit pour wade vous faites partie du
grand projet de dieu son esprit à
pousser chacun d'entre vous à s'engager
pour cette retraite
[Musique]
tu as lu ali c'est ça ouais bienvenus
c'est pas grave si tu pense que les
choses sont complètement bizarre je vais
avoir besoin de ton téléphone et de ta
montre cet amateur a pas besoin de
montres durant toute la semaine parce
que c'est jésus qui nous donnera le
rythme à puce
[Musique]
allez cette retraite ne servira à rien
si tu n'es pas honnête
alors qu'ils étaient déjà santé etc je
parie que tu as vraiment bouffer le nez
en gouaille je sais même pas ce que ça
veut dire
vous avez des courriers je suis ami avec
une perverse six copains
maintenant je suis mouillé doit gagner
pas si mouillé d
tu vois la vérité c'est que personne n'a
aucune idée de ce qu'il faut ou ne faut
pas faire
mais qu'est ce que tu fais on a tous des
secrets qu'on cache
et toutes sortes de secret
ton corps est un cadeau qui te vient de
vieux tutoie l'honorer health
pour le monde dit jésus-christ j'écris
[Musique]